they they launched a national
reconstruction
cleanup from the war program that
probably surpassed
the europeans clean up the vietnamese
really are the hardest working people on
the face of the earth the energy of the
vietnamese village and family and
community and nation
is just mind-boggling
as many as 70 percent of the women are
having miscarriages or showing stomach
tumors and problems from the docks and
the number of
deformed uh fetuses being aborted or
being born deformed is sky high compared
to a normal population my wife's family
the amount of rice the percentage that's
taken by the government is less than the
percentage of my dollars that's taken by
the government here in taxes takeover in
april of 75 there was no bloodbath
anywhere in the country
this is not to say that some people
didn't get killed but during that same
period of time
more people were killed by arvin more
civilians were killed by arvin than by
the communist forces i mean arvind
soldier is just turning their guns on
people
they put a hundred thousand people or so
in reindoctrination camps
they also kind of tricked them into i
mean they put out the word that it would
be one month's reindoctrination and that
would be it and people could rejoin
their society
soldiers the common soldiers were one
month and they were permitted to go back
home
uh but they're still people in
re-indoctrination camp we talk about the
vietnam war they've fought off they've
beaten off another invading giant since
we left i mean in 1979 200 000 chinese
soldiers invaded vietnam
and mind you oh yeah big thing and
that's close enough if you look at the
map you know they're only a couple
hundred kilometers from the capital from
hanoi this was a very threatening thing
and they had to fight them off and they
did and they beat them back across the
border
john stockwell served in vietnam while
working for the cia during the last two
years of the war
he recently made an extensive trip back
to vietnam and he tells us about it
tonight on alternative views
[Music]
hey
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
last summer when rambo was returning to
vietnam on hollywood movie screens
fighting and winning world war ii the
vietnam war and world war iii all in one
go john stockwell also returned to
vietnam to visit the country that he'd
served in as a member of the cia from
1973 to 1975.
john in fact was a member of the cia
from 1964
to 1977 and then resigned to write his
book in search of enemies that exposed
the role of the cia and his experiences
in the angola operation
john is now writing a book on his
experiences in vietnam the norton press
will publish next year and tonight on
alternative views john is going to
reflect on his vietnam experience on his
recent trip to vietnam and we'll discuss
some of the ideas that will appear in
his new book so john welcome once again
to alternative views my pleasure once
again john in our last program with you
we discussed your experiences the last
two years of vietnam and then 10 years
later you've recently returned to
vietnam so let's discuss this experience
on our show today can you give us a
little bit of a sense of what it was
like to go back to vietnam 10 years
after your previous experiences there
it was the hardest trip i've ever taken
in my life in every sense of the word i
think including
hard to organize
the way i got the invitation to go back
was i had married a vietnamese woman
that i had known in vietnam before
and adopted her child
and
she had gotten out in that april 75
evacuation
with
no opportunity to tell her family what
she was doing or give them an address
and they lived out of saigon down in the
delta so there was no way for her to
correspond with them
and they
they thought she was dead and she had no
idea of no way to tell if they had
survived or not
and so
thinking in in our various travels mind
you and 10 years have gone by
i've traveled all over the world
including going to cuba and grenada and
nicaragua to see other covert actions as
they're happening this is what i lecture
about this is what i write about
ci us corporate ci covert actions which
they've been running a long one against
cuba and they had a major one against
grenada that culminated in an invasion
and of course the famous one in
nicaragua
and i've traveled to many other places
as well like jamaica and barbados and
england and france and germany and
switzerland and hungary
and elsewhere lecturing and speaking and
interviewing but uh in cuba i thought
about it and then i asked the cuban
friendship society that hosts visitors
from if they mined it if i walked into
the north vietnamese or the vietnamese
embassy and
and uh talked to them about my wife's
family and they said sure why not you
know they encouraged
they encouraged me to understand that
vietnam is opening up and has relations
with the world and the war is a thing of
the past
and so i walked in and the consular
officer who met us
i had my wife with me and he said why
don't you write your wife it's things
are open you can write letters and send
packages
and she explained that they were down in
the delta and we didn't have an address
so he said give us their names and we'll
find them
and
this was a tough one because of all my
years of conditioning about communists
and and then miley had been in the south
and her father and family you know
involved on the on the one side subject
to the propaganda and the fighting and
everything and the concept of giving
the communists all of the names of your
family in detail it's really a tough one
a mental hurdle for her you know to get
over
she really couldn't do it i had to sit
down and kind of debrief her
i had to say now who was your father and
her mother and
she couldn't remember the names of all
her brothers and sisters she was just
blanking out just really blocking out on
the thing and i i got it all put
together and gave it to him
hoping i was doing the right thing
because mind you she was now
married to an xci colonel and you know
god knows the stories that we hear
the propaganda and whatnot but we did it
and a year later they sent word that
they'd found her family and that
everybody was well including her 100
year old grandmother
and so as soon as we could we got back
to havana to thank them and also see if
we could send letters and get addresses
and things and they said sure of course
but then they sprung a little surprise
on us they said why don't you visit your
family to her
and then they turned to me and said why
don't you visit vietnam
and uh i
could have fallen out of my chair the
their uh you know
do you mean it you know and like when
whenever you like
and so i said well next summer sure how
about christmas that's even better
so we proceeded to lay on the dates and
fill out the forms for visas and make
plan to come back in december of this
past year pick up our visas and go to
vietnam
now they told us that it would be the
10th anniversary and that the country
was opening up
we didn't know of anyone else who had
been back except karnoff to write his
book and cy hersh on researching some
things
but
it was quite you know once again an act
of faith of
that the country really is opening up
this isn't a ploy to get me back and
uh and i talked to everybody that i knew
that knew the vietnamese and they were
all saying i come off of it you know
you're living mentally back where you
came from it's uh
i talked to sai hersh who had been there
for example and others and what cubans i
know and
and they were all saying forget it you
know you're living in your paranoia and
they're trying to open up and join the
world
so we tried to go in december we went as
planned and they did not have visas
ready for us and they put us off and uh
very frustrating because i'd cancel
lectures and gone to the expense of
going as far as havana
but they promised us they were still
interested and we should come again in
april and we went in april on the date
promised and they still didn't have
visas
and so we got into serious doubts at
that point of their
you know how conscientious were they
about this and what was going on so
you'd actually made two additional trips
to cuba hoping you could get out to oh
yeah vietnam and the second one was last
april we sat in havana for uh for a
month the port council there i mean he's
at the end of the line he can't give us
visas until he gets the visas from hanoi
and uh he he's the one who extended the
invitation but his government hadn't
followed through
and so he's he a very gifted diplomat
very polite and very pleasant but in a
heart
he suggested that we go on to moscow and
that he would forward the visas when you
know
but you see this was a government
invitation and when our government or
any government invites people they
traditionally give them plane tickets
and uh we would have gone of course if
we paid our own plane tickets but that
was the invitation so we were there to
get and that was why we're going through
havana partly to pick up the visas but
also if they invite you they're going to
give you plane tickets on socialist
country airlines so they don't have to
pay out hard dollars
and which meant we'd have to go to
mexico to pick up
cubana and then cubana or araflot moscow
and moscow
incredible long you know flight but you
know i said wait a minute
i don't have a visa to go to the soviet
union i'll have to get a transit visa
how am i going to get a transit visa
unless i have proof that i'm transiting
which means we can't go to moscow i said
in addition to which what about the
plane tickets how are we supposed to get
the moscow he said
problem well come back next week and
and so we went back twice a week for a
month
and eventually they came
they came through with the visas and he
was you know he was greatly relieved he
was very proud and happy when he finally
gave us the visas
there was a delay from when we got them
until the time that we could uh
um actually you know we're supposed to
arrive and do our visit in vietnam
and so we did go
they uh
they they did uh one they explained to
me eventually what the problem was in
the delay is the fact that they they had
set up a committee to invite people back
now mind you that's back from the states
people have been going back from france
and canada and other countries all along
but the big breakthrough is whether or
not you know people will come back from
the united states vietnamese who left to
come here
and american journalist and whatnot
going in
they set up a committee to organize
these things and host and make it all
work and they built hotels and they've
got restaurants and things working
throughout the country quite well
and this committee came up with the idea
of finding miley's family and inviting
me us
in reference to who i am as a writer and
a public speaker and having been there
with the cia and now speaking out on
behalf of third world countries and
whatnot the committee thought that it
was a good idea
the trouble is as they explained to me
is that every government has other
committees as they pointed out
washington has other committees meaning
the fbi and the cia and all the others
uh it was apparently difficult for them
too well i was having all my doubts they
were having all kinds of doubts about
exactly what i might be up to and and
what not now they eventually worked it
out it just took them a while to do it
what they did was they they got us
together with miley's family and that
was absolutely wonderful it was just
a rare lifetime experience to have a
reunion after a 10-year loss of contact
and whatnot
little jonathan got uh
to spend five days
uh with his his vietnamese grandparents
on their farm they have a nice rice farm
way down in the delta right down there
and mind you the the vietnamese people
at least her family and it's they're
more affectionate than than americans as
a people they're more tactically touch
and hug and cuddle and kiss
more than we do and her family is
especially loving
so that it was it was very you know just
a very warm experience but they're such
uh caring people the
the ducks
you know will get up on the table while
you're talking and you you know feed
them and eat out of your hand the little
duckling will sit on the side of your
hand and peck grains out of your hand
while you're
uh the dogs and cats i mean
it's it's they're together with nature
and there's a sense of
of warmth there which of course for a
six-year-old you can imagine was just
and then he was the the young prince you
know coming back home i mean they
they were carrying them in places and
mind you it's wet rice farm
and and the home is actually on an
island in the middle of the place so to
get there you had to go by boat or these
little flat bottom boat things and back
and forth and it was it was for him an
experience of a lifetime although he
wants to go back and we might go back
that was the good part another good part
was they took us up right near the
chinese border and all the way down to
the south and just about everything in
between now mind you it's a it's from a
tourist point of view it's a country
that's full of
lots of attractions you could spend
weeks and weeks there just seeing things
things that date 2000 years in the
history and
we saw haifang we saw halong bay which
is this curious bay that has the 3 000
little marble islands it's a bay of
tonkin where the first incident is
actually
that's you know it started the war
or was used by johnson to justify our
entry yeah the pretext for starting war
we went to visit that which is uh one of
the wonders of the world
saw hanoi very well saw ho chi minh city
which everybody still called saigon even
in the north they call it saigon and
they explain they're not uptight about
it they just explain it well officially
it's ho chi minh city and for a nickname
we'll always call it saigon and unlike
the russians
who
live in vulgar garage still call it
stalingrad yeah yeah what did the
country side look like in the cities did
you see much
of continuing devastation bomb craters
and burned out places or was it pretty
well reconstructed not as much
uh the devastation of war as you would
expect uh and and other writers i
noticed because you know mind you a
number of writers and tv people went
point back at more or less the same time
we did
not as much devastation as you would
expect to see and a big reason for that
is that they they launched a national
reconstruction
uh cleanup from the war program that
probably surpassed the the europeans
cleanup the vietnamese
really are the hardest working people on
the face of the earth the energy of the
vietnamese village and family and
community and nation
is just mind-boggling the way they work
the hours they work and the energy they
put out
we used to see it when they would dig
canals before you'd order a canal but a
village would get out there and
everybody
and you'd just be amazed the way the
thing would just go until eventually it
would be a canal dug across the lands
they set a policy of erasing the war
and they took away the barbed wire and
they took away the bunkers and they
filled bomb craters where they could and
they went through
vast regions taking out the mines that
you know we had planted everywhere
and disarming bombs and uh they had
brigades set up to do it and there was
you know they they had casualties of
course but they just flat did everything
they could to erase the war i was
looking for the war
you would see occasionally a factory
that would have
the rubble the side you know blown off
that hadn't been rebuilt
you would see a temple that hadn't been
rebuilt the rubble you would see in some
places you'd ask and you know they'd
show you uh but mind you it's labor
intensity it's uh they they grow
on every inch of arable ground and so
that's all
it feels and everything
i imagine if you could do as we did
before and get in a helicopter and fly
over from above
you would be able to find more places of
bomb craters and whatnot but
the environment you know recovers and
grass grows and there's nothing in a
bomb
that will in fact keep the poison the
grass from growing back and trees and
bushes and things from growing back
we saw this in in 1972 the famous
invasion of cambodia
uh where arvin you know was was
decimated our own
uh detailed aerial photography showed
these vast fields and they had room for
maneuver
and they put these 150 tanks in
and uh and amtrak's and whatnot and what
they found was that all of these fields
were full of our bomb craters that
didn't show from the air even in 72
because they were going over but you
couldn't drive your tanks through the
areas
the area that's been that was defoliated
by us the dioxin and the burnings
one-seventh of the south was defoliated
completely at the time
and that including some of the best
lands
it's grown back
most of it virtually all of it
but the thing is that it doesn't grow
back i mean you can't make an argument
for defoliating you can't say well it'll
grow back
it you they had they had jungle you know
the primeval forest there
and that doesn't grow back that
ecological system is destroyed forever
other types of trees grow back
dominating that are scrubby
non-productive the
mahogany trees the productive trees that
were there will never come back and of
course some of those things a thousand
years old and 300 years old and whatnot
and all of that's lost
the changes in the fishing for example
because of the destruction in parts of
the delta where they could pull out 300
kilos per night on the better boats you
know they may get 30 kilos now and so
they've had to you know re-uh just
restructure the the economy itself was
the fish even fit to eat
well um international studies are done
and they've had conferences there with
70 nations sending people to study the
effects on the environment of the dioxin
for example alone the ancient orange
and uh this is the problem that the
country's going to live with for
you know who knows 10 000 years and it's
measurable in some of the hot spots
uh as many as 70 percent of the women
are having miscarriages are showing
stomach tumors and problems from the
docks and
the number of of
deformed uh fetuses being aborted or
being born deformed is sky high compared
to a normal population well the water
and the water table is the dioxin
doesn't deteriorate yeah the water
though the certain parts of the country
are poisoned virtually forever
the country is also overpopulated it was
before and now with the pressures of war
off it's it's a population explosion and
that's among the many problems that
they're having of
of recovering and is trying to you know
get this under control they can't afford
to have broad parts of the country
uninhabited for you know until the
dioxin deteriorates
it's not like angola for example where a
third of the country doesn't have a soul
living in it this is a
country that's that's jam-packed with
people
john and
for the 10-year anniversary i was up in
washington and saw the washington post
for his period of time
they had several days of special reports
and articles
and they were saying that there is still
quite a considerable well in one extent
there's a considerable north-south split
but on the other hand they say this
split is narrowing
culturally as much as anything else they
were saying that the south is affecting
the north because the south is more
americanized more westernized they like
their you know their
the western googles like the tape
recorders and they're more easy going
and they're wanting to make money etc
did you find this that there was that
big north south split
uh well yeah for sure historically
there's been one to a degree well
they've been you know the nation was you
know i mean the the myth the reagan myth
you know that the country was always two
countries and whatnot that's not true it
was a one country uh thousands of years
ago and it's been partitioned by
invading people and the french broke it
into three parts and then we partitioned
it
after dien bien fu in 1954.
um
it is it it you know there was a
national identity that goes back for a
long time but there's also regional
differences which are remarkable
and uh traditional and everybody in the
country will you know now and before our
vietnam war
could sit down and immediately tell you
about all the differences between the
north and the south cultural differences
eating differences
the people in the south traditionally
have it better than the people in the
north because the climate is more
favorable and they have fewer mountains
it's richer it's the delta
this has supposedly led them to be more
enterprising in terms of commerce and
trade it's a richer area
the north the people in the north tell
you about this talk about it when you
get off the plane
not exactly with jealousy but just
acknowledging the fact that people in
the in the south have always been more
inclined to comers
and business
not that the people in the north are
lazy or don't you see all of the same
things from the busy rice farming to the
trucks and cars and buses and ferries
going across the rivers and commerce to
the little businesses every house has
got someone out in front of it hammering
or nailing or rebuilding an old truck or
an old car or something or are sawing or
cutting or
are molding and burning bricks or
whatever
uh in the north and the south as well
the difference is you know we have to
remember our own country and our own
civil war in which the north won the war
there too and kept the country together
as the south was trying to secede uh how
long did it take those wounds to heal
reconstruction decades
120 years now you don't see any serious
stress between the north and the south
but when i was a boy there were people
who talked with great bitterness about
the damn yankees but i was living in
georgia during uh the 1940s during world
war ii they would re-fight the civil war
absolutely and with bitterness and in
fact back then we're about the same age
back then you would call
someone a yankee and that was fighting
insult i mean that was that was bad
stuff well it's you know so 120 years
later it has finally eased but 80 years
after the thing there was still
visible signs of bitterness and tension
and
it's going to take
80 years 100 years before all of the
wounds of the war will be healed you're
gonna have to have two and three
generations before the wounds will all
be healed
looking at it in that context and how
long it takes those kind of wounds to
heal
certainly and there's a restructuring
that's still going on there were people
who were
in power as administrators in power as
as you know in power controlling at the
local levels and regional levels in
capital and national levels
and this has been you know replaced by
another bunch of people and of course
this is going to lead to bitterness on
the part of the ones who used to live in
the big houses and run things who are
not running things anymore
there's a
americans who are going back are in a
mood to gloat at any sign any vestige
they see of american imprint on the
plays
and in my observation
they have greatly exaggerated this now i
have to be careful because some of the
articles you read
uh i i went you know i was sort of two
months after these articles were coming
out
and then i went
they may have made some changes in the
society from the time the the
william royals jr for example went and
wrote his article for the atlantic
monday he wrote his article in november
of last year and and then it came out in
april and i went in late may
um
he writes about how america won
the cultural war and he makes a heavy
point and i thought you know i i
accepted this with i read this but he
writes very convincingly and i thought
well what does you know what does it
mean winning a cultural war but i
expected to get off the plane and see
lots of people wearing american clothes
and trying to talk english and dancing
to american teens
and uh i didn't
this is one of the things washington
post says that is occurring all
wholesale over
uh south vietnam and is even affecting
the north well if
if they were reporting accurately and
it's possible that they were then the
vietnamese
took steps to change that between the
time they were there and i was there
either something happened because when i
went there you did not see young people
dancing to western tunes there was music
all over the place invariably vietnamese
now
one thing that americans are kind of
dumb about and and uh mr royals didn't
cover himself on this boy i'm sure he's
an intelligent man but he didn't cover
himself on writing this is
is uh
i mean to say that people are
americanized because they're wearing
blue jeans in 1985
means that you haven't traveled very
much really because i mean blue jeans
are worn throughout the world young
people are dancing to a certain type of
music throughout the world it's true in
singapore it's true in hong kong most of
these blue jeans are made in in
singapore and czechoslovakia
and not in the united states there is a
world culture emerging which young
people all over the world are
identifying with in rwanda in the heart
of africa they're trying to wear the
same clothes and dance to the same tunes
and they don't see this as an in moscow
they are they don't see this as being
americanized it's a world culture
some of it originates with us but but
our musical themes and our jazz came
from africa have we been africanized i
mean it's it's you know it's a world
culture that's spreading across the
place
but even that
it was not as visible to me as it was to
all these people and since i wasn't
there when they were there i was there
two months and six months later i have
to say that either they didn't report
well or the situation had changed
it's quite possible that uh the
vietnamese saw all these articles coming
out and were stung by people gloating
that we had won the cultural war and
changed vietnam to model american
cultures
that would hurt them because they're
very proud of their families and their
cultures and it's quite possible that
they just
it suddenly went out of fashion to be
dancing to american tunes in the streets
john my guess is it's probably the
the american reporters over there seeing
one or two examples they would jump to
conclusions because that was what they
were trying to
it's probably a little bit overlooked
you see what's familiar also yeah you
see what you're
used to looking for i think though it's
probably a bit of both probably the
vietnamese uh suddenly realized
the way it would look to foreigners and
took steps to
to
to make some fairly subtle changes
royals probably saw
some incidents of americans you know
also he kept saying in his car you know
all the music you heard the guy driving
his car probably had the radio station
to a singapore
you know the car radio to singapore
radio station on american music as a
courtesy to his guest
and because i played with radios and you
could find occasionally a western song
but all the other channels were in
oriental languages john one of the major
divisions in vietnam has been between
the country and the cities
the countryside and the city and
particularly after the war people fled
from the countryside into the city and
they had problems of vast overpopulation
and they've been trying to deal with
this problem and to build up the
countryside what was your experience in
this regard did you see overpopulated
cities
where the countryside and the rural
areas more impoverished where they're
beginning to rebuild
the big rush to the cities was not after
the war it was during the war when we
were forcing people to leave you know
the their homes their farms it was a
rural a country in agrarian society
originally
we defoliated and bombed and forced you
know a million or so people to move more
than a million several million to move
into urban areas
and then in addition to that at the end
of the war people are right at the end
of the war people were kind of crowding
into the cities because they were afraid
and there was some mythical sense that
they would be safer in the cities which
they would they would not
the first vietnamese effort to get
people back to the farms didn't really
work that good
but these were the new economic zones
yeah
and uh they have uh
recognized their mistakes and how they
organized these things
essentially they tried to force people
to leave the cities and force them back
to farms without enough to provide for
them enough care for crops and
provision and to make it attractive
and so people would stay as long as they
had to and then run away back to the
cities
now two things have taken effect one is
a wiser program on the part of the
government to encourage people to go
back to the land and two people finally
realizing that it just life is not as
healthy and nice in the cities
and so people being much more receptive
so they have a program whereby
now relocating people the same economic
zones but take they'll take people back
on a voluntary basis instead of forced
they will let them go they'll pay their
way and take them there and let them go
and stay a month to see if they like it
so they'll have a chance to talk to
other people and look around and get the
mood and then the man will go and or he
will stay and the family will come six
months later to join him permanently
which will give him time without having
babies to feed to get you know get crops
going and get the
the process with this approach they're
finding people standing in line to
volunteer to go back to the country and
get their own property and begin to
produce all they're also changing their
agricultural system since the night
early 1980s where previously they had a
fairly heavy collectivization
of agriculture so the people went to the
countryside they were in state-run
collective farms where the state would
control agricultural production
completely but haven't they begun to
allow a certain mixed economy here where
the farmers can
sell to the market some of their surplus
goods and that's the people in the
country can make more money and have a
better standard of living
absolutely
[Music]
and and
they're not wedded to an ideology that's
going to [ __ ] themselves they're
trying to find what works for vietnam
and they found that you know that people
are going to work better if they can
a certain amount of their rights has to
go to the government
this is as old as vietnam the peasants
have fed the emperor's armies you know
two thousand years ago and
and it's it's the major resource of
south vietnam or the southern part of
vietnam
but my wife's family the amount of rice
the percentage that's taken by the
government is less than the percentage
of my dollars that's taken by the
government here in taxes
this was quite a revelation to me
their overhead and their cost it's it's
uh even with a good farm like they have
it's a rough life the farm and the hot
sun
anywhere and particularly there
[Music]
but like i say percentage-wise they keep
more than i do
i've also read in the guardian they had
a real good article
about like you say the experiments they
tried the kind of rigid
soviet type of experiment and
economy and that didn't work
so as you've said doug they had the
they changed the farming the agriculture
system
they're also trying to
delegate to lower levels to bureaucracy
so it won't be so rigid and dogmatic and
that they also got
decided to do away with rationing but to
give a big uh
raise in wages to people so they could
buy their own food and that seems to
work so it seems they seem to be very
eclectic and seeing what's happening in
other socialist countries as well as in
them
did you have any uh talks with any uh
bureaucrats or government leaders about
their experiments
i did but this was one of the weaknesses
of my trip we were invited back to see
my wife's family
and they didn't know what my interests
were and uh
we talked about another trip but
in which i would be invited back to meet
leaders and talk about these things in
great depth we had lots of conversations
with people endlessly as you traveled
and had lunch and all of this about just
these things but i didn't get briefed i
didn't really get into it the way i
wanted to
i've seen uh well you remember back
during the war they were saying oh we
got to stay in there because we gotta
because we've got to prevent this
bloodbath that's going to occur when the
north vietnamese took over
the north vietnamese have handled that
in a very interesting uh way and without
a bloodbath yeah that was practical
israel is ideological that's part of
that april 75 it was ambassador martin
and the french ambassador marian was it
were encouraging people to believe that
when the communists were liberating
areas there were bloodbaths occurring
they were fomenting these rumors
to strengthen their position it was
counterproductive in a way because of
the fear
and panic but they were definitely
encouraging the rumors of communist
atrocities
because they wanted to make it you know
to galvanize opinion and get get people
to rally to their side as opposed to
rallying
to the communist side
the
journalists and witnesses at the time of
the takeover of saigon
said that it was the most
described it as the most benign
takeover by a conquering army in in
in history perhaps
and the the key to that is that the
armies of the north really did not see
themselves as a conquering army they saw
themselves as reuniting the country that
had been artificially separated a
liberator liberator and you saw those
pictures in the streets of the people
welcoming in saigon the army coming in
to kick out the south vietnamese
government you had
soldiers
in va as we call them people's army as
they call them soldiers
setting up their little tents in the
first days and weeks until the thing was
sorted out setting up their little tents
under the trees and the little parks and
things and the dirt between the
boulevards
and cooking their water chestnuts and
rice which they'd been eating out in the
jungle for years while the population
around them had chickens and fish and
vegetables and food
this
you know very much betrayed the the
image that was created now mind you
the image was fed by mistakes that the
communists had made and other times
in way during the tet offensive they
there were atrocities they were not as
extensive as the western propagandists
made them out to be but there were
atrocities there were
there were graves uncovered with bones
in them
uh and then when
[Music]
the agrarian reform campaign when when
they they liberated north vietnam from
the french
and there were people who were
arbitrarily killed in that thing ho chi
minh admitted that that was a mistake
and they corrected it when he saw what
was happening
these were the things that fed the fuel
were used later on to justify
the concept and mind you
right next door to us just six miles
from where i lived and slept was
cambodia and at the same time that
saigon was taken over by the communist
forces cambodia non-pen was taken over
by the communist forces the khmer rouge
and they did affect the bloodbath and it
was hideous
we expected the same thing to happen we
were sincere i mean the propagandists
were feeding the fires and certain
ambassadors were
encouraging uh these rumors but we
sincerely expected a hideous thing to
happen and we just didn't understand the
sincerity of our of our enemy of the
people we were fighting for this period
of time well there must have been some
repression afterwards and there were
these relocations and these re-education
camps well they put
[Music]
they put 100 000 people or so in
re-indoctrination camps
they also kind of tricked them into i
mean they put out the word that it would
be one month's reindoctrination and that
would be it people to rejoin their
society
soldiers the common soldiers were one
month and they were permitted to go back
home
but there's still people in
re-indoctrination camps the figure you
know everybody disagrees on what the
figure is the lowest that i've heard
by international scholars and
journalists is 30 000 still in camps and
some people say it's a hundred thousand
it's quite a bunch of people i've read
where they have already released
thirty thousand
former south vietnamese officers
including several generals
and
they did it for two reasons five you
know humanitarian
reasons but also they said that somebody
said well why haven't you given these
people a trial
and they they said well if we gave him a
trial we might have to execute him and
we don't want a bloodbath yeah
because these are some of the some of
the most hideous corrupt butchers yeah
that they could have imagined but there
wasn't widespread no killing no there
was no blood there were executions there
was no bloodbath during the takeover in
april of 75 there was no bloodbath
anywhere in the country
this is not to say that some people
didn't get killed but during that same
period of time
more people were killed by arvin more
civilians were killed by arvin than by
the communist forces i mean arvind
soldier is just turning their guns on
people
the south vietnamese soldiers killed
more people than the north they they
their conduct was at some you know the
discipline broke down they were
frustrated they were panicking and uh
they were turning their artillery on on
mobs of southerners fleeing and their
guns on them the north retained its
discipline it never at any point as it
marched through cities in the south
turned its soldiers loose and let them
become a rabble storming the city
and so there were fewer atrocities
committed by them than by the southern
soldiers at the end john we've
seen the phenomena of the boat people
people fleeing in south vietnam
and the according to a recent article i
saw the u.s embassy in bangkok says
there are still 584 thousand people on a
list of vietnamese people who want to go
to the united states
i wonder what your opinion of that is
and uh if you think it's fairly accurate
that there are still that many people
who would like to i would presume that
there are uh
you know again i mean let's face it in
any that would represent about 140th of
the population and
[Music]
there are not many third world countries
where you couldn't get 140th of the
population to come to the us if there
was any hope that they could i mean
that's a simple fact 140th of mexico
would certainly come up here in fact
they do despite the laws
and haiti and argentina and everywhere
else we have quotas to keep them out
in addition to which
you had an artificial
economy in vietnam where we were pumping
in billions and billions and billions of
dollars in cash and in materiel and
suddenly we pulled out
and that dumped the country back into
its own resources dumping it back five
decades in time and we had not built an
industrial infrastructure so conditions
in the country really did plummet with
this with you know take away this
artificial source of hard currency and
medicines and all these things that were
coming in
in addition to that they had the contact
with with westerners and with americans
and there were there were lots of them
of women who had american children and
people who worked for the americans and
had a sense of
of knowing america or americans and a
dream so to speak left in their mind as
they see their country go back to
reality
and uh without question it's a hard life
in a in a poor country and people who've
had a glimpse of of their country
splurging
for 10 years on incredible sums of money
no question about it there are lots of
vietnamese who would like to get out
who've tried to get out some of them
risking their lives in boats to get out
i you know if i were there god knows
maybe i would try to get out
i would
we deal with this problem in terms of my
wife's family and of course a lot of
them would like to come and live over
here
but with our limited resources i'm
convinced that they would be better off
if we spent the money
on them
as opposed to spending the hundreds and
eventually thousands of dollars to get
you know get them out we can't get them
all out
and the money for fifty dollars a month
you can live quite well you know to
supplement to set yourself up in a
business and use that to expand your
commercial
uh possibilities a hundred dollars a
month you can live you know a family can
set up a business and thrive
whereas that amount of money you know
here
good luck and and
and while the vietnamese have been the
most successful wave of immigrants
coming into this country
let there be no question it's been hard
for a lot of them the relocation the
cultural change the laws and this is not
a country that's easy to come in poor
and make your way
there's a lot of government u.s
government assistance too
that was not available to waves of
italians and polish or even poor
americans or poor americans yeah
i i uh you know i see this in my dealing
with refugee organizations here and
whatnot and they
you go and talk to them about getting
your wife's family out and the first
thing they tell you is
talk to them realistically about do they
really want to come out or would they be
better in the bosom of their family
there
john the
vietnamese have faced some
tough
uh problems as far as natural disasters
i understand there was a terrible flood
in 1978 that was just about the worst in
their history which caused considerable
problems and then of course they had the
drain on the economy from the cambodia
operations
the war with china and 1970 oh yeah
americans are oblivious of the fact we
talk about the vietnam war they fought
off they've beaten off another invading
giant since we left
i mean in 1979 200 000 chinese soldiers
invaded vietnam
and mind you oh yeah big thing and
that's close enough if you look at the
map you know they're only a couple
hundred kilometers from the capitol from
hanoi this was a very threatening thing
and they had to fight them off and they
did and they beat them back across the
border it was a war it wasn't a little
raid or something it was a war here in
the united states they had us think that
it was just some little border skirmish
here's a little incursion now this is to
we're two wares ago now and then i must
say they did something which i
personally do not support uh although
it's my position and it is of no
importance to anyone in the world except
myself but this is putting their troops
into cambodia
and they took advantage of the chaos in
cambodia that existed
although they were never hypocritical
about it they never claimed that they
were going in there to save lives or for
humanitarian reasons
the reason they went into cambodia was a
historical
friction i mean cambodia had conquered
vietnam at one time and they'd conquered
cambodia and there's a
back and forth in history
vulnerability on the one hand but also
cambodia looking down onto that rich
delta that underbelly of vietnam with a
huge common border with it with the
underbelly and china attacking from the
north
and trying to put in a government and
control a government in cambodia that
would be hostile to vietnam
and vietnam they just decided that they
weren't going to have it
and so after the chinese invaded them
from the north
they put their armies into cambodia and
the pol pot government also had led some
military incursions into vietnam
i don't recall that there had certainly
been friction i don't recall in what you
could call an invasion was there well
i've talk to people who were there near
the border and there'd be some shelling
and occasionally some soldiers come
across oh there was definitely that sort
of friction i i've definitely heard that
yes and what about the validity
the idealistic validity of them saying
that they also wanted to save cambodia
from the butcheries of pol pot
they which were just about as horrible
as you could find in the history of the
world the for sure the the the bloodbath
there the two or three million people
who were
died from
being butchered and from the famine
the vietnamese
in fact put an end to that but they have
never claimed that their invasion of
cambodia was for humanitarian reasons
they they did throw the khmer rouge out
and paul pot out
but uh they
they've been they have worked with
international organizations but they've
been fearful that we're trying to go in
with food for the cambodian people but
they've been fearful
that these international organizations
were trying to get back into to
undermine
their own programs and they've been very
suspicious with good reason we always do
and
[Music]
so they there there has been more so the
cambodian people have suffered more than
they needed to what is the status of the
vietnamese vietnamese army that's now in
cambodia
is it a permanent occupying force are
they planning to leave at any time they
have talked this last spring about a
willingness to get out a willingness to
pull out and they said that they're
sending some troops home
and
uh i this is this is the sort of thing
that i was hoping to get into with the
leaders if i had met them or if i go
back
now and do meet the leaders that i want
to talk to them about to whatever extent
they'll talk to me about it and see what
their prognosis is
it's u.s policy to try to force them out
we would of course like to set up our
own government and
ironically we support paul pott
we were supporting pol pot when jimmy
carter was our president with a
humanitarian theme in his presidency and
he was butchering people so
the chinese also support pol pot but
john now the vietnamese been very
dependent upon the
russians for help
the russians also have a huge
hydroelectric
system and dams that they're
putting up supposed to be
operational about
1987 but i noticed in the paper that
some u.s businessmen are going over
there
and they're particularly interested in
agriculture in food distribution and oil
which is interesting because this is
what some of the radicals the anti-war
radicals were saying all along was the
primary interest of the united states
going into vietnam in the first place
huge deposits of offshore
oil
to date this oil has not materialized to
date
the the major corporations who could
help vietnam pump the oil are claiming
that the resources are not that easy to
tap
that they may have been exaggerated and
in fact vietnam has not been able to
bring in hundreds of millions of dollars
from oil
uh i my own guess is that in time they
will that in time
you know we've got a glut of oil in the
world today and the corporations are not
interested in dumping more oil into that
glut
my guess is that it's uh
it's a resource that's going to come in
10 or 20 years when we do in fact make a
bigger dent into the world's fuel
supplies
then vietnam will have its time of
wealth and there's another factor too
we're friends with china now and china
has asked american corporations to help
develop their oil and their oil is the
same oil as vietnam the oil doesn't stop
at the border it just continues on down
south indeed and and china of course is
claiming islands that have traditionally
belonged to vietnam and we're allied
with uh
of course you know as part of that our
alliance with china and the pressure
we're putting and realities harsh
realities of the world this is all why
vietnam is trying to open up
they they could they could you know
maintain uh
an island and keep people frozen out but
they're not going to keep up with the
rest of asia much less the rest of the
world unless they do find a way to get
into world trade
and this is what they're you know this
is why they're opening they're trying to
get tourism
john to conclude our discussion since
we're running out of time can you give
some final reflections
on your feelings going back to vietnam
10 years after
and of what u.s foreign policy should be
towards the vietnamese well a great
range of very powerful emotions i
i found myself getting very upset
depressed and upset in the first days it
was so beautiful and the people were so
nice and this this agrarian countryside
where the war has been erased so you're
looking at
rice fields and water buffalo
and friendly people everywhere you stop
the car friendly people smiling with
that incredible vietnamese warmth
and trying to figure out why anyone 10
000 miles away in my capital
would want to bomb the place much less
be able to rationalize doing so
the the diabolical madness of the people
that fly
37 000 you know a feet up in the air and
and b-52s and pull levers and punch
buttons and drop strings of bombs and
down in rice fields down below
and the people in the white house
kissinger plotting his maps and drawing
circles and fly here and bomb this and
yet the us itself hasn't done anything
to normalize relations with vietnam well
i was on my way to vietnam i read that
[Music]
first the cia director casey and then
schultz both stopped in bangkok and held
press conferences announcing that they
would
reopen covert activities against vietnam
working from thailand
it's pretty sick and when you're down
there on the ground thinking about that
i had trouble coping with it
and then also thinking the heat and
talking about health conditions and
thinking about the people that we
hired and drew into our working for the
us government and left behind and it
really struck me that you know those
people of course still in
re-indoctrination camps today we've
heard from some of them and some of them
have gotten out and others have
died
and
[Music]
i got i got upset i spent one day i was
i had meetings and things and i was
gonna
i got up they were supposed to start
about eight and i got up at six and went
out and i walked the entire
uh circumference of hanoi i walked 30 or
40 kilometers that day i went around the
city and zigged through it and around
the lake
uh crying much of the time just think
trying to cope with all of this and
think about it and it was very
depressing and eventually i worked my
way through it
great excitement and warmth
to to see the way the country has erased
the war and see the energy of the people
and the beauty of the place
and the friendliness of the place
[Music]
that and then my lease family is as
wonderful and warm as they were and that
was a surprise because i hadn't met more
than a couple i met a couple of her
sisters and her mother
uh
the the the handsome people
and so friendly and so nice that was
wonderful and the effects for jonathan
it was a trip that had a great range of
emotion
thank you for joining us tonight on
alternative views
we'd like to thank our director david
galicic camera person judy burton and
also austin community television ac tv
for the use of their equipment
alternative views is a production of the
alternative information network
po box 7279 austin texas 78713
views can be seen now in 22 cities in
the country plus 12 suburbs or chicago
and it shows to
about oh two million six hundred fifty
thousand households in the country this
means that somewhere between five and
six million people will have the
opportunity to see alternative views
each week
we hope everybody does and you return to
watch us next time
good night